i accidentally became a meme and this is
that story
my name is david devore but you may know
me as david after dentist
is this real life my name is also
david devore and i'm the dad who
recorded the
video this all started in 2008 my life
was pretty normal you know just school
sports friends seven-year-old things
the reason david had to have the surgery
was because he had a condition called
hyperdoncho which is just
an extra tooth it's more common than you
think david's was up
in this general area but it was headed
toward his sinus cavity and that was
going to cause
big problems in his teen years i was
pretty nervous because i had never had
surgery before growing up i loved
watching
those crazy er horror stories
so that probably didn't help the reason
i wanted to record
to be able to show david afterwards you
know his anxiety before and after and
how it wasn't so bad are you nervous yes
yeah yes you know this surgery was not
your typical
wisdom tooth uh being removed just the
regular
laughing gas or nitrous oxide was not
gonna cut it so they had to use ketamine
and i remember them telling me to count
backwards from 10
i remember thinking there's no way
i'm not gonna make it to one and then i
don't remember getting past eight they
took me back into the procedure room
and you could just tell david was uh he
was out of it i've seen drunk people and
that was pretty
he was like hey papi but he kept
pointing at three
people you know i love you poppy i love
you poppy i love your poppy
i remember being really blurry and they
were just holding carrying me into the
car and being lifted up
you know ketamine is an incredibly
strong uh anesthetic
i'm okay it has side effects i feel
funny you know double vision
you know deep existential experiences
is this real life why is this happening
to me
it's okay bud stay in your seat
i think he just finally just accepted it
that this was his life right now
after the surgery i basically got to go
home and watch star wars
and eat ice cream it was a pretty good
day after
that first part i knew i had captured
something and when
we all saw it we're just dying laughing
rolling on the floor literally i didn't
post the video
right away it was actually a year later
posting the video was really just
more out of convenience to be able to
share it more easily with family and
friends
i just wasn't thinking anybody was gonna
see it so why not just make it public
posted it on a late friday night kind of
forgot about it
played golf before the super bowl and
then we kind of started checking it
on sunday and we had 10 000 views and
we're like okay
what's going on by the following
wednesday we were up to
somewhere between three and four million
then it just started going crazy
it was a week and we were in new york
for the today show already doing
interviews tv shows
the word meme had like just been coined
i just didn't think much past a lot of
people thought the video was funny and
they wanted to talk to me about it
back in the early youtube days the ads
partner program was like there wasn't
any communication from youtube it was
just a little
button to click on the side and i didn't
know what that was
another youtuber reached out to me and
he basically said dude you gotta
click that it's a good thing and so i
did but waiting a week probably cost me
uh
maybe ten thousand dollars my life after
was oddly pretty normal kind of like
disaster girl
i kind of have a double life every once
in a while i'm asked to
be david after dennis for a few minutes
i have not done any drugs since then
that was definitely enough drugs for me
reality is hard enough
i don't want to try and tackle another
dimension of understanding the world
all in all data for dentist has been a
blessing
and i think my teeth look great
[Music]
you